Elson Rapunzel are two of our favorite
Disney characters ever but did you know
that these two have a lot more in common
than meets the eye keep watching to find
out how their magical powers are
connected Disney has given us some
amazing girl role models and both
Rapunzel from tangled and Elsa from
frozen totally fit that description at
first glance you might think that these
two don't have much in common
Rapunzel spent her life not knowing she
was royalty she was more than a bit
helpless in her Tower but she proved
herself to be a fierce princess once she
got away from Mother Gothel Elsa grew up
with her parents the king and queen of
arendelle but when they were lost at sea
she was forced to grow up quickly and
become the queen of arendelle way before
her time Rapunzel's magic is in her hair
but Elsa's is in her hand and it's
totally out of control but these two
actually have a lot in common first of
all they both grew up in isolation
Rapunzel was locked away in a tower by
Mother Gothel her kidnapper was the only
person she saw for the first 18 years of
her life Elsa wasn't isolated at first
but when her powers accidentally hurt
Anna her parents kept her locked away
she was technically a prisoner but she
stayed locked in her room away from
everyone including her sister
we are also pretty sure that these two
Royals are related in frozen if you look
closely you can see that Rapunzel and
Eugene have come to arendelle for Elsa's
coronation arendelle is supposed to be
somewhere around Denmark and tangles
takes place around Germany they are
fairly close on the map and Rapunzel's
mom looks a lot like Elsa's dad
lots of people think that Rapunzel is
actually a cousin to Anna and Elsa and
the facts are pretty convincing but
that's not the only way that these two
are connected their powers are totally
similar according to several fan
theories
Rapunzel gets her powers from the Sun
drop basically a beam of sunlight drops
to the world and gave a flower magical
powers
this flower had the ability to heal any
injury and even stop sick people from
passing away when Rapunzel's mom was
pregnant she felt terminally ill the
king sent guards out to find at the Sun
drop they took it away from Mother
Gothel and made a tea from the petals
the Sun dropped tea saved the queen of
corona it also gave magical powers to
the baby inside her Rapunzel was born
with hair that had
all the powers of the Sun drop that's
why Mother Gothel kidnapped her she
realized if she cut the hair the power
stopped the Sun drops healing powers are
activated by a healing song and in
Rapunzel's tangled adventure we see just
how powerful the princess truly is she
is the Sun Drop now and she is destined
to unite her powers with the moonstone
to save all of Corona once her hair grew
back it became virtually indestructible
then there is Elsa she has ice powers
she can generate ice and snow with her
hands for a long time she doesn't know
how to control her gifts this is partial
because her parents made her conceal her
powers so she never got the chance to
master them but once she outs herself as
powerful she runs off into the mountains
she learns pretty quickly how to control
the ice she is able to create lots of
beautiful things with it she gives
herself a special dress she builds a
whole ice palace she is even able to
make a snow monster Elsa is extremely
powerful the only thing that can stop
her from unleashing her powers are the
shackles and cuffs Hans trapped her in
these are likely made with some sort of
magic and of course Elsa learns how to
reverse her magic with love when donna
sacrifices herself to save Elsa Elsa is
able to break the spell she even saves
her sister but we don't actually know
where her powers come from many fans
have pointed out that else's gifts might
be genetic when young Elsa freezes
toddler Anna their father immediately
starts searching through old books for
an answer he finds that there was
someone else in the past with these
powers and some suspect this mystery man
to be Elsa and Anna's ancestor King
Agner locates the troll village by
following a map he finds in a book it
leads him to the trolls who happen to
know exactly how to reverse Ana's frozen
state so since the troll map was in king
aegon r's library it's safe to assume
that a long time ago someone else in his
bloodline was frozen by magic alpha and
the Rapunzel both get their magic from
nature
Rapunzel's power comes from the Sun
itself and that way it's kind of
opposite of Elsa's the Sun is a source
of heat but Elsa's powers are really
cold both of their powers affect their
hair color Elsa's hair is almost white
like snow Rapunzel's hair is full of
magic and is the color of
the Sun Rapunzel's Sun drop abilities
emanates magical healing properties Elsa
on the other hand is almost the opposite
well she can create things her powers
are also destructive as a child she
accidentally put her sister's life at
risk as an adult she causes a huge
blizzard to freeze the kingdom of
arendelle
she totally ends the spring season and
it causes a lot of problems
Rapunzel's powers come from the universe
whereas Elsa's powers seem to be more
earth-based that's because of the trolls
the trolls are made of stone and only
exists on earth they are able to heal
people in Reverse Elsa's ice spells when
need be but while their powers might
stem from different places
they're both rooted in the power of love
in Tangled Rapunzel's tears are able to
heal Eugene her hair had already been
cut but her tears still worked with the
healing song the power comes from her
love for eugene and elsa is able to save
anna and all of arendelle because of her
love for her sister so why do Rapunzel
and Elsa have magical abilities and if
their powers are genetic does that mean
Anna is going to reveal abilities of her
own and frozen to the trailers make it
look like someone else has some
nature-based magical powers like the
power of the wind it's also basically
proof that the entire Disney Universe is
connected we can't wait to learn about
Elsa and Anna's family tree in the new
movie and we really can't wait to find
out more about Rapunzel's Sun Drop
powers in season 3 of the tangled series
what do you think is going to happen in
frozen to let us know your fan theories
in the comments give this video a big
thumbs up if you think anna has powers
too and make sure to subscribe to the
things for more awesome videos like this
one thanks for watching see you next
time
[Music]